rick and morty season five just ended
and there seems to be a massive
disparity in quality for episodes this
season so i thought it would be fun to
rank them and go through the strengths
and weaknesses of each episode without
further ado we have number ten
you probably guessed what would be at
the bottom of the list and it's easily
rick dependent spray out of the entire
show i think this is the worst episode
which to be fair there isn't a lot of
competition for that title for rick
dependent spray though i think it
utterly fails at what makes rick and
morty so great
firstly the character journey for rick
and morty is extremely hollow
they don't really learn anything or go
through a character arc that teaches
them some kind of revelation from the
beginning i assumed rick knew about
morty sperm being in the horse sperm
container and he was intentionally
letting everything play out just to
teach morty a lesson
but that wasn't the case and it makes
this whole journey feel pointless since
our characters learn nothing besides
morty just needing to be less horny then
we have the contrived scenario that
kickstarts the conflict which is simply
rick being stupid
there were at least four moments where
rick was like hmm something is off and
morty is clearly losing his composure
but rick never figures it out the
writers even admitted the episode was
contrived and it feels like they were
too lazy to cut it out of the season
even the premise is overly crude and
disgusting like it would make sense if
the concept of the episode was stellar
and they had to have a contrivance to
kickstart it but they were willing to
sacrifice the quality of writing to
shoehorn in morty's sperm taking over
the world
then also throwing in a bunch of other
crap like a random underground horse
society and an incest space baby all
that really overloads the episode to the
point that the pace is unbearable
then for the comedy there were maybe a
couple moments where i snickered but a
lot of the main jokes failed for me like
blazen having the humiliating and
awkward death and all the characters
acting stupid for the sake of
comedy number nine gotron jerry sis rick
van gerien
really the only strength this episode
has over rick dependent spray is that
the concept is at least intriguing
but even then they don't really go that
deep with it and the story feels very
superficial i think dan harmon's quote
unquote story circle this episode is
compromised because of how the
characters act throughout
everyone besides morty feel like they
are way out of character
we have summer who in this episode is a
complete and manipulative [ __ ] who
pushes rick into a dark place just to
elevate her status in the family rick
who acts like a child and has no
self-control and apparently it's up to
morty to keep rick in check now then we
have beth and jerry who are [ __ ] talking
their own children and disgracing them
like what the hell is happening
we go from beth caring for her kids a
few episodes prior to her hating them
now i gotta turn my back on you no
with morty out of the way things were
looking up there is absolutely no
consistency and the episode goes through
a contrived manner of everyone acting
out of character just so that they can
have the revelation that they need to
work together as a family
also the whole sibling superiority
conflict between morning and summer is
really stupid and meaningless because we
know that fundamentally rick likes morty
more and whenever summer challenges that
we know that morty isn't in any actual
danger
then the whole episode is drown out in
voice over as they rapidly speed through
all the plot developments
it boils down to morty and summer
explaining to us what happens as we miss
out on all the details in essence it
shatters a role in writing of show don't
tell and the writers fail at proper
narration
generally the characters should not
overly describe the plot or what's
happening but instead have an internal
monologue as to how they feel about
something it's okay to explain the plot
at some points but doing so throughout
is just lazy writing
especially since there was barely any
conflict in the episode and the second a
decent obstacle arose it was drenched in
contrivances like rick being an idiot
and trusting the anime people and
randomly introducing that summer is
taking care of an incest space baby
also when she was telling the story she
said the baby escaped the government
compound but then the family used it to
help rick
how the hell did they find the baby how
did they
i'm not gonna bother
so yeah i thought this would be a fun
episode but i was definitely mistaken
[Music]
number eight
amortican griffiti
to me the most annoying issue with this
episode is that the main plot has a
repetitive joke and concept of demons
finding pleasure and pain
initially it was funny with them
enjoying the cringe of jerry but once
they go to hell the concept doesn't
really deepen and it stays in its simple
stage of pain equals pleasure in every
single moment
then rick comes up with a random
equation to turn pain back into pain dad
what is that an aversion converting
inversion reverter it shoots
concentrated pleasure pain inverting
shrapnel which reverts the pleasure from
pain back into the pain from pain we're
gonna kill them with a hundred percent
sincerity which i guess i'm just too
dumb to understand but at least they
don't portray rick to be an idiot in
this episode this overall plot was
enjoyable and i especially liked how
betrayed jerry was and i actually felt
bad for him at times however this whole
episode is utterly dragged down by its b
plot in which morty and summer try to
impress bruce shutback by taking him on
an adventure firstly bruce shutback was
just a non-character and had no
character traits so this was basically
just an excuse to have an extension of
the keep summer safebee plot from season
2.
except this time the subplot takes up
about half of the run time of the
episode and the main characters
practically had no input as to what was
happening so they were just watching
random [ __ ] unfold for 10 minutes that's
fine for a short duration as it was in
season 2 but for half the episode really
because of that there was no real arc
proper character development or
interesting story events that occurred
in all that time
number seven rick and morty st
exploitation spectacular
i'd say out of the lower received
episodes of season 5 this is the best of
the bunch the main credit i give towards
this episode is that at least the story
and concept are creative which leads to
somewhat of a fun time however it never
feels like these outlandish concepts are
logically justified in the story like
rick and the president being randomly
obsessed with turkeys for reasons
it seems like the writers just wanted
this wacky idea to happen despite its
completely outlandish concept being
impractical within the story then the
whole episode plays out in which rick
and morty don't have much to do for the
entire run time they feel like
background characters and are just along
for the ride while the president is
making all the crucial decisions that
drive the plot like in the end rick and
morty are literally just following
around the president as if they are
servants taking orders
along with rick getting saved on
multiple occasions by the president
which makes him seem even more like a
dependent background character
then when looking at some of the main
jokes of the episode the writers
constantly go for the low-hanging fruit
of political jokes
making the 10th joke bashing how stupid
politics are is making me depressed if
anything so even though the concept is
cool and ambitious as if this was some
kind of superhero movie the writing
mostly deteriorates the execution for me
number six a rick convenient mort
so finally we've made it to what i think
is the first mostly good main plot on
this list
and when i say mostly there are some
flaws that i have with morning
planetina's relationship arc it seems
pretty contrived that planet tina is so
willing to go out with this random kid
that ran up to her on the street and
asked her out
literally the only impression that morty
made on planet tina was that he recycled
one can
which i guess is all you need to secure
a date with her the second issue i have
with this main plot is that we see morty
essentially hit rock bottom in terms of
depression and there doesn't seem to be
any lasting impact on his character from
this episode that kind of downplays the
climax of the breakup but besides that i
think the rest of the main plot was
great two standout scenes being morty
killing planet team's manipulative
children and a twisted avatar of the
last airbender kind of way and the
montage of morty and planetina's
relationship declining that montage
easily bumps this episode up and seeing
morty devastated as planet tina turns
into a super villain is tragic then like
amortic and griffiti i dislike the
b-plot of this episode it felt like
filler to me and was a research of rick
dating unity
i do like the coordination of how both
rick and morty hit some kind of low in
terms of love but on rick's side it felt
shallower and more boring since they
were just pardoning the whole time
[Music]
number five morty plissett
this was a very unique type of episode
for rick and morty i feel like it both
excels in some areas while it falters in
others
so in terms of the areas it excels in i
think the premise was a fun idea having
this cascading ripple effect of clones
creating clones and having them all
fight each other because they are scared
of being hunted is crazy
it leads to a lot of great moments and
the concept of rix getting lazy down the
line and creating clones with less
effort gives the episode its much into
depth this in turn creates a lot of
variety amongst clones and it gets
pretty wild like when a family gets
captured by a deformed rick who skins
other clones to provide skin for his
family
to even puppet like clones providing
sanctuary for other scared families
this episode is chocked full of so many
fun moments and i think the tension
escalates really well and it climaxing
with an all-out war
now going back to where i think the
episode falters is that it lacks a
consistent perspective in which we
experience the story
because the way the episode plays out is
that we quickly get tossed around a
dozen or so families as they are trying
to figure out what is going on
in the beginning whenever we switch
perspectives it felt like the
progression of the episode was
regressing because we were constantly
restarting with a new family but once
the first half finishes and we get into
the last chaotic half of the episode the
two steps forward and one step backwards
conundrum wasn't an issue anymore
overall morty plistet was a smart
creative one-off episode that is easily
re-watchable
number four
forgetting star rick mort chow it was
really hard choosing between morty
plisted in this episode because i think
they are pretty similar in quality the
only difference in slight edge i would
give to for getting star rick mortichow
is that it has some solid story and
character growth
which i tend to value highly when each
season only has a few episodes including
story progression
but for this episode on its own i think
the reveal of morty cleaning up rick's
problems was a magnificent development
which then leads into the funny moment
of morty filling up the portal gun with
mountain dew and getting portal fluid on
his hand
as a result of that we then have rick
getting very upset with morty and this
essentially highlights the lowest point
of their relationship
and at the end of the episode i think it
comes to a great revelation where rick
realizes how toxic his relationship was
with morty
so on the character relation front i
thought it was outstanding however i
personally didn't like the two crows
direction that the writers took and rick
being overly and weirdly obsessed with
them it felt too wacky to me and i never
thought it was believable for rick to
throw away everything for two crows
which does speak to the outlandish
comedy of the scenario but that's really
the only thing that brings this episode
down for me because i think morty's
journey far and away outshines ricks to
crow's journey and come on morty cutting
off his own hand and throwing into the
guy's thigh portal to kill him was
insane and badass
number three returnal frenchon of the
spotless mort
one thing that this episode does
perfectly that the others don't really
do that well this season is the pace
it feels refreshing not zooming through
random complex scenes and slowing down
and focusing on one simple objective
that is imbued with a cool concept
despite the climax being a bit confusing
but that has made up for an epic ending
that seems like it references the ending
of halo 3.
besides that though i think this episode
has an extraordinary balance of lore
building while simultaneously moving the
story forward by having set pieces take
place in the memories of bird person the
writers can naturally showcase events in
the past without copping out with a
flashback it's so intriguing finding out
all this backstory while also not being
bored since rick is actively moving
towards an objective throughout the
episode
that and after re-watching rick turner
friendship again for this ranking there
are some small moments that allude to
the revelations we figure out at the
final episode like rick killing these
different versions of himself and one of
them saying this
killing us won't bring her back
thanks for the info but i'm more on a
revenge kick than a results kick i think
that's a great detail that rewards
re-watchability
also the direction they took the story
with the revelation of bird person
having a baby and him figuring out how
rick withheld that information for his
own benefit was perfect
number two
mort dinner rick andre
i think this episode works so well
because the stakes are drastically high
for morty because he finally is getting
some quality time with jessica so any
and all obstacles that are thrown at him
feel that much bigger because of those
stakes
and that being said the obstacles that
morty has to overcome are crazy and
inventive
the whole different dimension type plane
where time moves faster and morty has to
battle a rapidly advancing civilization
just to get rick and mr nimma's wine is
an outstanding concept
which that then domino effects into a
crazy set of events where jessica gets
kidnapped and turns into a being whose
mind has transcended her physical body
in terms of flaws there's only one small
issue that's not really that big of a
deal but rick feels neutered in this
episode in terms of strength he does get
his weapons taken away which is
justified with a joke but even when he's
in his own garage which is essentially
his home turf he still gets manhandled
by mr nimbus
like was the garage ai just munching up
popcorn as rick got the [ __ ] kicked out
of him it's just a little inconsistent
when literally the episode prior rick
had some sort of defense system when
clone bets showed up
however though this doesn't really
matter that much since morty is the one
that takes the spotlight and his
adventure was refreshing
number one
rick mirai jack
for the finale i feel like it by default
deserves the top spot purely because of
how well it sticks to landing at paying
off the evil morty storyline
to me the story development was pretty
much flawless and we finally get the
long-awaited backstory for our two main
characters
the reveal of rick's filtering out other
universes controlling morty and
manipulating his conception and the
complete revenge field backstory of rick
with the company of a synthwave
soundtrack was magnificent
the only flaw here is that it feels like
the creators are uninterested in
devoting a lot of time for canon and
backstory so they opted to do a big dump
in the span of five minutes
and this issue connects back to the flaw
of pacing in that this evil morty arc
and backstory extravaganza takes place
in just 13 minutes
that's pretty wild and right after
watching it i felt like i needed a
re-watch because of how fast it ran
through the material
i wish the writer spent the whole
episode on this area instead of tying up
loose ends from the episode prior and
doing a samurai jack parody
they could have easily saved this parody
concept for another episode but throwing
it into this finale feels like they're
overloading it a bit
besides that flaw i don't feel like it's
enough to really discount the quality of
the finale the climax was epic and i
especially like the evolved and more
layered version of evil morty's theme
it all comes together in a bombastic
finale and you're left speechless as to
what just happened
it's just a shame that it could have
been as good as the reclantus mix-up had
the episode of devoted all of its time
to the evil morty arc
it's crazy how we can have episodes that
are easy contenders for the top 10 best
episodes in the series and then others
that easily make it into the worst
i just hope for season 6 that they can
make the quality between episodes more
consistent but if they don't then at
least we will probably get some bangers
at the end of the season if you enjoyed
the video let me know in the comments
and i can also do an episode ranking of
the other four seasons of rick and morty